- Recently, someone asked me
what the most important element
of a business slide presentation is.
And after thinking about it for a bit,
it was very clear to me that Action titles
are actually the most important elements.
So, if by now you're not really sure
what an action title is or how to come up
with a very, very strong action title...
Welcome to another video here
on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, I'm a
former McKinsey consultant
and on my channel I
talk a lot about topics
such as career success and
also consulting skills.
And surely as a consultant,
one thing that you really need to do well
is to create slide
presentations in PowerPoint
or any of these other programs.
So in today's video,
I want to sharpen your understanding
why action titles are so important
and also give you some
very, very tangible tips,
including an exercise to help you
come up with the best
possible action titles
that you can write for your slides.
Let's start by looking
into why action titles
are so important.
And the key point you have to understand
is that your presentations
should have a storyline.
And it is the action titles
that bring this story to life.
The main idea is that
if you read your titles
of your presentation from start to end,
so every single slide,
just read the titles.
The key idea is that by just doing that,
you will be able to understand
all the key messages
of the presentation just by
reading these action titles.
So, why is this even necessary?
Why is this important?
Well try to put yourself into the shoes
of a C-level manager, you are a CEO,
CFO, any other business unit head,
any other senior guy in an organization.
Likely, especially these
large blue-chip companies
that often these
consulting firms work for,
these C-level people, every
single day, every single week,
they will get several big documents,
50 pages, hundred pages, or even more,
of other projects that are going on.
Project updates, progress
reports, deliverables like that.
This is far too much to read.
People like this cannot just read
every single slide of documents like that.
So, what they will expect you to deliver
is a document where they
can just skim through,
just read the action titles,
and just by reading the action titles,
be able to understand
all the key messages.
And this is the so-called
horizontal logic,
the storyline of the presentation.
This needs to come to life
via the action titles.
And then the idea is, of course,
that if they read something
in the action title
that is really interesting,
where they want to learn more about,
then they stop and then
they read the page,
they read the full slide.
This then is the vertical logic.
And here, of course,
you already understand one key thing,
when writing strong action titles,
and this is that, of
course, an action title
should summarize the contents of a slide
in a clear and concise way.
So, this is the intuition,
but now you might ask yourself,
what exactly is an action title?
So, I try to put down here in definition,
this is coming from
myself, so no fancy source,
just my best way of putting it in writing.
And I would define an action title
by being a header of a slide presentation
that summarizes the content of the slide,
by formulating a complete sentence.
So, if you wanted something
like here the header,
also here on top of this slide, saying,
"Action titles help to
create a clear storyline
within the presentation."
This would be the action
title of that slide.
This is what you want to try to achieve.
But what do you write in such a title?
What are the contents supposed to be?
And here I think the best
test that you can do,
is the test of the so-called "So what?"
The question of the "So what?"
And I once created a full video,
just about the concept of
asking this question "So what?"
I will link it somewhere above here,
if you're interested to
learn more about this
you're free to check it out.
But in a nutshell, the
"So what?" is a question,
that you as a project lead
might ask to an associate,
or consultant who prepared the slide,
or maybe a partner asks to you,
and this person looks at your slide
and asks him or herself
the question, "So what?"
Right? So, so what, why is this relevant?
What is the implication
of what I see here?
Because maybe the information
on the slide is interesting.
It's data. It's nice.
But what does this mean
for the problem at hand,
for the thing that I need to solve?
So in putting together the document,
you should ask yourself,
what is the "so what?" of the slide,
if we really struggle to
come up with the "so what?"
then this often is a sign that this slide
maybe isn't that important, right?
If it does not have a clear "so what?"
maybe it's something that
rather belongs in the appendix,
but maybe not in the main deck,
or maybe take it out completely.
But once you know the "so
what?" make sure the "so what?"
is clearly stated in the action title
and then of course, when
you're presenting the slide,
then the "so what?" is also
what you should be communicating
in your presentation.
Now let's look into a
couple of best practices
that you should apply whenever
you write an action title.
And here we'll always have an example
and then an insight that I
want to draw out from that.
Here the first example is,
"managing risk is important
for this project success."
And here, my answer is try to
avoid statements like that.
Try to avoid writing general truths
that are pretty much always correct.
So of course, managing risks
is pretty much always important
for this project success, right?
So for almost every project
that will be relevant.
So try to avoid writing
things that are obvious,
really draw out more
insightful things than that.
Next, something like,
"all divisions have found
to not be following best practices."
What's often dangerous,
is to write action titles
with really hard absolute statements.
Always, never, in every case,
this is like this, or like that.
So these are very hard
statements often are traps
because there are often
some weird edge cases.
Maybe there is this, like very
little division somewhere,
who does something that
you were not aware of.
Just my personal learning that often,
and especially for presented,
maybe there was like one board member
sitting in the audience will tell you,
'no, but this is not
correct, this is wrong.'
Because you know, it's just enough
to have one example that contradicts this
and then pretty much you're there
and need to admit that,
yes, your message was wrong.
What you put on the slide was wrong.
It's not the case that this
is true for all divisions.
Next one,
"Company has potential to
significantly improve profit."
So here my learning from that is,
try to whenever possible, to
quantify the action titles
include numbers in the action titles.
So if you make a slide
about profit of a company,
usually you should always be
able to also put a number.
So what is the profit
improvement potential?
What is the potential for the profit
that you see in the company?
Next one, "When conducting
data analysis and interviews,
we learned a lot about the business."
So this would be an action title,
which very much focuses on the process.
So what you did, you analyzed data,
conducted interviews, you learned a lot.
This is often not so relevant.
People don't really
care to who you talk to,
what analysis you conducted.
What people are interested
in are the results.
This is one of the key
fundamental principles
of top down communication.
Again, I don't want to go too
deep into this in this video,
but I will link another video that I did
about top down communication
above here, check it out.
Really one of the most
fundamental concepts
for communication as a consultant,
but also in general, in any
professional environment.
Last example here,
"Results indicate significant potential
to look into further improvement
measures for the business,
with the goal to increase profits by 50%
until end of this financial
year for the company."
So, frankly, I don't even
know what exactly this means.
The point that I wanted to make here is,
write action titles in a concise way.
Don't use more words than necessary.
Yes, usually there will
be a full sentence,
but don't just write
for the sake of writing.
The rule is that usually in the title,
you should not have more
than two lines of title.
So two lines are fine, but
not write more than two.
Now let's put your action title
writing abilities to test.
You see here a standard slide,
it's from a mock-up
presentation, of course,
not any actual line engagement.
But what you see here is a slide
where the action title is missing.
And I want you to come
up with an action title
and now to help a little bit out,
here I would just like briefly
explain what you see here.
So here you see a sizing
of a growth potential,
every potential for this company,
that could choose to enter these markets.
So the North America market
or the Asia Pacific market,
and then you see different
numbers, you see the market size,
you see how much of the market
is covered by competitors,
the current market share, and
other considerations like this
and in the end, also an EBIT potential
that the company could receive
from entering these markets.
Now, I would encourage you
to maybe even pause the video
for a moment and think about for yourself,
what would be a strong action
title for such a slide.
If you want, even write it down.
So let's look at a couple examples
of what you could have written.
So the first is "Derived
potentials for an expansion."
And again, feel free to always pause
and think about this for yourself.
Whether you consider
that this is a strong action title or not.
Because indeed, I would argue,
this is not even an action title,
this does not even meet the
definition of an action title.
This is a title in the style
that I know many people like to do it,
but it's just not what I
would recommend you to do.
And this is, for instance,
if you have a page
that describes the risks
of a certain strategy,
then just writing risks
in the title, right?
So it's a title, but
it's not an action title
in the sense that it doesn't summarize
the key message of a
slide in a full sentence.
Next one, "Expansion to new geographies
creates a positive EBIT potential"
EBIT, by the way, for the uninitiated,
stands for earnings
before interest and tax,
and pretty much is one
metric of profit, right?
So what is the profit, the
profit potential, of the company.
So what do you think
about this action title?
And here I would argue that
yes, it meets the definition.
I mean, it is an action title
following the definition,
but I would argue it's
not the best action title
you could write,
because indeed this seems far too generic.
You could be much more tangible,
much more concrete here.
But let's look into a
couple of other examples.
"Expansion to North
America and Asia Pacific
creates a positive EBIT potential."
I mean, yes, I like it.
It's a bit more rich of information
and not just talking about geographies,
but are really mentioning the geographies
you're interested in.
But here, quantify if possible,
Just look at these best
practices whenever possible.
Especially whenever you
have numbers available
at your disposal,
put them in the action
title and quantify it.
Next one,
"Expansion to North
America and Asia Pacific
creates a positive EBIT
potential of 22 Euro million."
So yes, here I would argue, it's fine.
It's already a very strong
and solid action title.
Though, here you could argue
that this is then a little bit too wordy.
You could write this in
a bit more concise way.
Usually the fewer words
you use the better.
So here one example,
"Expansion to North American Asia Pacific
with 22 Euro million EBIT potential."
And I would argue that, yes,
this is a good and solid action title.
Here what's also important to understand
is that you can write these action titles,
you do not need to write them
like you would write, like,
proper full sentences in a book.
It's completely fine to
take out certain words,
often you take out articles,
any other filler words,
which are not absolutely necessary
to understand the key messages.
Obviously you would probably not write
something like this as a
full sentence in a book,
but here is concise action title.
This is absolutely fine.
So hope this makes sense to you.
So I know that in the
Firm Learning community,
there are many other people
who are also quite experienced
with action titles.
So if you have any tips, or insights,
or other comments on this video,
please leave a comment below
in the comment section.
I trust that we would all
very much appreciate that.
Maybe you've already noticed,
that this is a remake
of a video that I did
as one of my very first
videos on this channel.
I just felt like the video back then
was not really up to
the level of the quality
that I do the videos today.
And the topic is just so important
that I just wanted to
do an update on that.
Hope you still found interesting.
Also if you've already
watched this quite old video,
and if you've watched it,
thank you for watching,
for learning, for that long.
I would never have thought
that I grow to the point
that I do right now, when
I started in January, 2020.
Thank you for being here
with me since the beginning.
As always, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to this channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
If you want to see even more from me,
I also create content for LinkedIn,
Instagram, TikTok, and Twitch.
Links to these socials
in the video description.
There you can also sign up
for my email newsletter,
and of course last but not least,
a big, big thanks to all
the members of the channel.
You're really making a
difference for Firm Learning.
Thank you so much.
My name is Heinrich,
I release videos every single Saturday.
So see you again next
week, until then, bye-bye.